hey how you guys doing
hi how are you
i'm good so i'm a big fan of horror
films and i was pleasantly surprised to
see how creepy this season is caleb on a
scale of one to ten how scary do you
think season four is
oh man um
i it's a give i'm gonna say 10 but like
that's a real answer like
like a solid like
eight and a half nine
um i don't know i was trying to get deep
with it but uh
like really pretend i would say 10
because i i was watching the season and
i was like wow
yeah this is i don't think anyone should
let their kids watch this
it's like you really see a lot of stuff
happening like in detail like it's very
gory
so
i yeah i agree no that's a good answer
because just when i thought the
demogorgon was scary you've got vechna
now and this is like a whole new level
uh gayton were you surprised at how
scary this season is yeah i think so i i
knew that they always wanted to up the
stakes every season that they make i
know that's always the goal i mean you
look back at interviews of us doing
press four the first for the first three
and we always say that it's scarier than
the last and it's the biggest it's been
and that's always the case but this year
i mean it feels redundant for us to say
it but it truly is just absolutely
massive and i think
yeah i was really shocked to see at what
scale they were going to bring it and i
think it's crazy considering we still
have another season to up the stakes
even further
yeah which i love and you know sadie
just when we thought max was going to
have a bit of down time you know she
went through a lot season three still
mourning the loss of her brother billy
she gets thrown into an even more
terrifying situation uh what's the
journey like for max's season
yeah so we find max like you said just
grieving the loss of
billy her brother
and
i she's really shut herself off from her
friends because i don't you know she
doesn't want anyone to know what pain
she's actually in
um
but i think i think just
isolating herself ends up being
it causes more harm for her than good
because
you know they they start to just these
thoughts just kind of eat away at her
and then eventually um i don't know well
i that's a spoiler never mind i'm gonna
keep my mouth shut
[Laughter]
i'm so close would you say though that
this has been quite the emotional
rollercoaster for you this season or do
do you sort of feel that with every
season on the show
this season especially yeah i think you
know season season two was just like
hello i'm max and then
season three was um i don't know more
like fun light-hearted side
of her but then season four it's just
i don't know you've never you've never
seen her like this and she's really i
don't know she's
ugh she goes through a lot
yeah a lot is a good word uh priya i
feel like i can never get enough erica i
love that we're already seeing the sass
level up another notch this season what
can you tease us about erica
um
you know you definitely see what erica
brings to the team and how she forms
these bonds with
lucas and um lucas friends so you
definitely get to see a little bit of
that and a little bit more of her
personality you get to know erica a
little bit better on
yeah just her personality and how she
kind of what she brings to the team like
i previously said and how she her bonds
with all these wonderful
people so
i like that um you know with with the
groups all kind of everyone's separated
you know everyone's in kind of different
areas
of the world how would you say that kind
of uh adds its own flavor to this season
compared to what we've seen from past
seasons yeah i think uh it is really
pivotal in how the plot drives forward
because i mean we're used to being
together we're used to
being able to relay back to each other
whenever we need i mean usually
throughout the uh to see the course of
the earlier seasons we do branch off
into separate storylines but at least we
we always know that we have each other
and that we're at least in the same area
but now it's it's gonna be a great
challenge for us to try and uh get this
done while being in different parts of
the world and without any contact with
each other uh it's really it's it's
gonna be a it's a big big challenge and
it's something we've never experienced
before and
it's scary
it's so scary honestly you guys i loved
it so much i was watching it like one
o'clock in the morning and i was like
yeah i shouldn't have done this
thank you so much